tonight during his first major foreign
policy address at the state department
today
president biden says he will seek to
raise the annual refugee cap
to 125 000 in his first year in office
up from 15 thousand set by the trump
administration
meantime on the u.s mexico border some
facilities are at capacity
tonight due to a steady increase in
border encounters since april 2020
and also coveted restrictions some
migrants are now
being provided a notice to appear and
released into the u.s to await a hearing
what critics call catch and release
national correspondent william laginess
has specifics tonight from los angeles
william
well brett customs in border protection
says because of that steady increase in
apprehensions
mexico's reluctance to accept more
deported families
and covert restrictions here some
facilities are at
maximum safe capacity therefore it says
per long-standing practice when
long-term solutions
are not possible some migrants will be
processed for removal
provided a notice to appear and released
into the u.s to await a future
immigration hearing now this is needed
they say to avoid keeping migrants
beyond
what court orders allow so right now the
border patrol is stopping some 3
500 migrants per day trying to enter the
u.s
former dhs director chad wolf calls it a
perfect storm
likely to get worse as smugglers and
families exploit the situation
it's a significant development that
they're not taking certain family units
back
under title 42 that's
very concerning because if you're just
doing that in one or two sectors
it's likely going to manifest itself
across that border in the very near
future
so right now this catch and release is
only happening in parts of texas with
some families with kids under 12 but
especially in sectors
with large increases in unaccompanied
children apprehensions like
big bend up 98 percent 55 percent
in the rio grande valley which
apprehended roughly 7 thousand children
in just the last four months
forcing the administration to add beds
in donna texas and carrizo springs
which last saw large numbers in 2019.
as for those released the new dhs
director says all migrants will be
treated fairly
those who qualify under those laws
are entitled to the relief that we
extend those who do not
will not be able to remain in our
country
so unlike those arriving overseas by
airplanes say
those released have not been tested by
covert or for
bike or for covet by cbp unless they
show symptoms
concerned border mayors have asked for
and received thousands of test kits
from the state right william
live in l.a william thanks another big
story tonight nearly 35